Speaker 1: We have been increasingly concerned
with what's going on with abortion rights
in the United States.
And the message that I had when Donald Trump
became president and started selecting people
to the Supreme Court was they're not giving
up.
They're going to try.
They're going to do everything they can to
make abortion illegal.
And they're going to do it by appealing cases
to the Supreme Court.
And they did it, and we are now waiting to
see what the Supreme Court decides.
But in the meantime, states aren't wasting
any time.
Oklahoma Republicans have passed a law forcing
a woman to have her rapist's baby.
It is a near-total ban on abortion, with no
exceptions for rape or incest.
This isn't going to stop.
They're going to keep doing it.
Gov. Kevin's tit, who's the governor of Oklahoma,
says as governor, I represent all four million
Oklahomans and they overwhelmingly support
protecting life.
We want Oklahoma to be the most pro-life state
in the country.
We want to outlaw abortion in the state of
Oklahoma.
They're not kidding around.
The bill also says anyone found guilty of
an abortion.
Think about the language, Gill, if you're
found guilty of an abortion, you can get up
to 10 years in jail and a $100000 fine.
There are cases where convicted rapists don't
get 10 years in jail.
And a $100000 fine.
Some got only a few months jail time.
And Oklahoma Governor Stitt signed the legislation
and it nearly bans all abortions in Oklahoma.
The only exception left.
The only carved out exception left is to save
the life of a pregnant woman in a medical
emergency.
And, of course, who gets to decide what such
a medical emergency is now.
One of the odd things about this new law is
that Oklahoma already has a law on the books
banning all abortions, except when necessary
to preserve the life of the pregnant person.
The old law only has a five year prison sentence.
The new law ups the maximum to 10 years and
$100000, so it's not even.
We have no law and we are anti-abortion, so
let's pass a law.
No, no, no, no, no.
It's.
We already have a law.
We just don't think the punishment is strict
enough.
So let's pass another law.
It's become a race to the bottom with these
Republican culture wars, and we could all
be living.
I mean, modern technology and medicine and
innovation would allow us to be living in
an age sort of sort of led by science and
enlightenment.
But we are fighting a group of people that
is determined to have a country based on extreme
Christian fundamentalism.
And many of these Republicans, when you talk
to them.
They're anti-abortion stance is based on a
religious belief.
It's not a science based belief, it's a religious
belief.
Now, strictly speaking, we have separation
of church and state.
Formally, you're not supposed to be able to
justify a law with religious doctrine.
In other words, it can't be written in the
law that because of what the Bible says, abortion
is illegal.
But all of these Republicans are using the
Bible to justify their votes, for sure.
I'm not saying there's any way to prevent
that.
I mean, you get into some really dicey First
Amendment issues, but understand that we have
plenty of law in this country that is based
on the religious beliefs of the elected officials,
and they're entitled to those beliefs, for
sure.
But strictly speaking, officially, those beliefs
can't be the state's justification for a law.
And again, I'm not saying that the free exercise
of religion should be suppressed, but religion
is being used at the individual level to get
all of this stuff done.
Now there's an important upcoming event.
It is very plausible.
I don't know.
I don't know that I want to call it likely.
I want to maintain some optimism.
But it is possible that Roe v. Wade is in
its final days because we are expecting a
decision in late June from the Supreme Court.
Last December, the Supreme Court heard arguments
in Dobbs v. Jacobson Women's Health.
Sorry, Dobbs v. Jackson Women's Health Organization.
This is a Mississippi case, and it's asking
the court to overturn Roe v. Wade.
And there are six justices currently on the
court who are at least open to overturning
Roe v. Wade.
Some of them are eager to do so.
Twenty two states already have abortion bans
on the books.
And so if Roe v. Wade is effectively overturned
by the forthcoming Supreme Court decision,
those 22 states already have laws that basically
ban all abortions, and most of those would
take effect immediately if Roe v. Wade is
overturned.
A fascinating but grim reality is that some
of those abortion bans in certain states.
Predate Roe v. Wade.
They are really archaic, and those are the
anti-abortion laws that that would immediately
be in play if Roe v. Wade is overturned in
late June by the Supreme Court.
So the framework is already there, and we
could be seeing the United States rapidly
accelerate to a sort of sci fi dystopian situation
with a resurgence of sort of back alley slash
underground abortion clinics, people leaving
states in order to get the services they need
elsewhere.
You know, I often say we do.
We don't want to point to a slippery slope
when there is unlikely to actually be one.
We don't want to unnecessarily fearmonger.
That's a tool of the reactionary, right?
This is a very real possibility that we are
now facing.
And Wisconsin's law makes abortion a felony
punishable by up to six years in prison.
That law is over 100 years old.
And it's not likely to be repealed, meaning
if Roe v. Wade is overturned, that's the Wisconsin
law that goes into place.
It's not been relevant because of Roe v. Wade.
Scary times ahead.
Very, very scary times ahead.